son élan peu par des oui fait c'est ici
en pleine forêt que domingo cisneros a
décidé de s'installer avec sa femme il
ya 20 ans tout monnaies dans le monde
digital nom de plus en plus en somme
perdue usines allemandes de pixels la
forêt ceux qui nous on aime la vie ce
qui nous donne l'oxygène ce qu'ils nous
ont l'emploi c'est aussi la forêt qui
nourrit son art il utilise le bois des
plumes des eaux pour créer ses
sculptures ont été exposées au musée de
saint jérôme au musée de saskatoon
pendant beaucoup d'années je m'accepte
est pas un paint et artistes
je le trouvais trop élitiste moi je me
concerne est un guerrier culturelle
contre la guerre contre a beaucoup de
coaches et plus dé surtout la nature
aussi sur la situation de la planète il
nous reste 12 ans selebi d'enquêté
il faut continuer à se battre domingo
cisneros est arrivé au canada en 1967
anne ans avant le massacre de clac
locaux au mexique le 2 octobre 1968
l'armée mexicaine tir à bout portant sur
des étudiants qui manifestent contre le
gouvernement
dix jours avant les jeux de la ville de
mexico quand l'armée et la police
mexicaine on a valu à certaines saisons
et le faire disparaître
impressionné a lâché l'ex idole des ados
étaient prisonnières ont disparu dans le
ps move y étaient là aux états unis à
s'étendre là et qui à cannes il arrivé
là
la massacrer 12 octobre ça me révolte
est totalement c'était il ya 50 ans
installée au québec depuis il continue
son combat pour l'environnement
soutenu par sa femme antoinette qui a
traduit ses écrits en français le
extrêmement inspirant ce
quelque chose de très authentique donc
c'est irrésistible
je peux pas je peux pas rester inerte
devant des matériaux qui ont l'air
d'être des là aussi des déchets des
rebuts de la littérature mais pas du
tout ces deux extrêmes des pépites d'or
je pense que la société québécoise et
mondiale a besoin d'une américanisation
d une africanisation de la
nationalisation à l'est les sociétés
traditionnelles ce que nous de montrer
quoi était vraiment comment vivre avec
la nature et ses cinquièmes quoi
signifier par exemple la générosité ou
les partages tous à caissons de valeur
ce qu'on a oublié qui n'a tué dame tous
notre société s est pas question de
baisser les bras
à 76 ans domingo cisneros garde toujours
la même fougue son rêve
enseigner à ciel ouvert dans cette forêt
qui lui est si cher on a besoin les
réarmer le service général des services
et à faire tout un homme est venu battre
contre tous deux signent justice
[Musique]